.
WE HAVE TO GO AFTER THESE
TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS AND HIT
THEM HARD.
WITH A COUNTER EXTREMISM.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IT IS NOT
EASY FOR SOMEBODY TO DECIDE THEY
WANT TO HARM SOMEBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN WEAPONS.
MY HOPE IS THAT OVER THE NEXT
FEW DAYS AND WEEKS WE ARE BEING
SOBER ABOUT HOW WE APPROACH THIS
PROBLEM.
WE LET THE FACTS GET DETERMINED
BY THE INVESTIGATORS.
BUT WE ALSO DO SOME REFLECTION
ON HOW TO BEST TACKLE WHAT IS
GOING TO BE A VERY CHALLENGING
PROBLEM.
NOT JUST IN THIS COUNTRY AROUND
THE WORLD.
MARK: WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE TRAGEDY IN ORLANDO
FROM ALL SIDES TONIGHT. WHAT
DOES THE SHOOTING MEAN FOR THE
U.S. WAR AGAINST TERROR?
JOHN: THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
IN THESE MOMENTS, WE SOUGHT
AFTER PARIS AND BRUSSELS, AND
SAN BERNARDINO, THERE IS A
HEIGHTENED DEGREE OF FOCUS ON
THE ISSUES AT HAND.
THERE IS NOT PERFECT UNANIMITY
AMONG THE PARTIES.
THE ISLAMIC STATE IS AT THE CORE
OF THESE EVENTS.
WHETHER THAT IS THROUGH DIRECT
RECRUITMENT OR IDEOLOGICAL
RECRUITMENT, THERE IS BROAD
AGREEMENT THAT HAVE TO TRY TO
WIPE OUT THAT THREAT ABROAD.
THE QUESTION IS HOW WE GO ABOUT
DOING IT.
DEALING WITH THE HOMEGROWN
ELEMENT OF THIS.
WHAT CAN WE DO WITHIN THE
BORDERS OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS GOING TO BE A THOROUGH
DEBATE FOR THE REST OF THE
CAMPAIGN.
IT IS A HORRIBLE EVENT.
I THINK IT SHOWS HOW MUCH
DIVISION THERE IS AN HOW TO
FIGHT THE WAR ON TERROR.
HOW MUCH WE NEED TO SACRIFICE IN
TERMS OF INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY.
THE VULNERABILITY THAT THERE
SHOWS TO US SINCE 9/11.
IT SHOWS JUST HOW UNABLE THE
COUNTRY IS TO STOP SOMETHING SO
SIMPLE.
JOHN: THERE IS A KIND OF CORE
LEVEL UNANIMITY ON THE TOPIC.
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE WE HAVE TO GET
THE ROOT CAUSES.
THEN THERE IS A QUESTION OF
TACTICS HOW TO GO ABOUT THAT.
THEY'RE PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE PARTIES
ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH ROOT
CAUSES AND ALSO QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW MUCH WE READ DEFINE OUR WAY
OF LIFE.
HOW MUCH DO WE ENLIST HIGH-TECH
COMPANIES IN THE EFFORT TO ROOT
OUT PEOPLE HAVE AN EXTREMIST
IDEOLOGY.
ALTHOUGH SINGS A VERY MUCH ON
THE TABLE.
FOR A DECADE WE WAITED FOR THIS
TO COME HOME.
NOW IT HAS VERY MUCH COME HOME.
IT WILL BE A BIG AND ENERGETIC
DEBATE.
THIS SHOOTING HAS RUN NEW CALLS
FOR TIGHTER GUN CONTROLS.
-- RENEWED CALLS FOR TIGHTER GUN
CONTROLS.
THE WEAPONS PRETTY -- USE ON
SUNDAY WERE PURCHASED LEGALLY BY
THE SHOOTER.
THIS DEBATE IS PERENNIAL.
WHAT YOU THINK THE SHOOTING
MEANS FOR THAT DISCUSSION AND
THAT ARGUMENT?
MARK: ZERO.
AFTER EVERY MASS SHOOTING THERE
IS TALK ABOUT STRICTER GUN
CONTROL LAWS.
BECAUSE OF THE NEXUS HERE WITH
SO MANY OTHER ISSUES INCLUDING
NATIONAL SECURITY I DON'T THINK
THIS HAS ANY CHANCE OF HAVING
ANY IMPACT ON THE DEBATE ABOUT
GUN CONTROL.
JOHN: THAT IS PROBABLY RIGHT IN
THE SHORT TERM.
BILL BE FRONT AND CENTER IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
-- BUT IT WILL BE FRONT AND
CENTER IN THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
IF HILLARY CLINTON MAKES THIS
CENTRAL TO HER CAMPAIGN AND
DEMOCRATS TAKE CONTROL OF THE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE DOES THE
POLITICAL CIRCUMSTANCE THAT
CONSTRAINS ACTION IN THIS AREA
CHANGE?
HILLARY HAS BEEN PUTTING THIS
FRONT AND CENTER FOR MONTHS NOW.
SHE MAY BE LAYING THE GROUNDWORK
FOR HAVING THAT HAPPEN.
MARK: I MEANT IN THE SHORT TERM.
IN THE LONG-TERM HILLARY CLINTON
IS GOING TO BE THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE CANDIDATE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY
ADVOCATING MORE AGGRESSIVE
CHANGES IN GUN CONTROL LAWS.
THIS EVENT IS SOMETHING SHE WILL
TALK ABOUT.
IF THE CONTROL OF CONGRESS
CHANGES AND CLINTON WINS IT
COULD LEAD TO CHANGE.
THE SHORT-TERM DEBATE IS NOT
GOING TO BE ABOUT GUN LAWS.
REPUBLICANS CONTROL OF CONGRESS.
AND A LOT OF STATES.
JOHN: THERE IS NO ISSUE ON WHICH
THERE IS MORE CLEAR DIVISION
BETWEEN HILLARY CLINTON AND
DONALD TRUMP THIS VERY ISSUE.
THERE IS A PREDICATE BY
SECRETARY CLINTON BEING LAID
DOWN HERE.
IF WE ASSUME THIS IS NOT THE
LAST ATTACK OF THIS KIND THAT WE
SEE ON THE HOMELAND AND CERTAIN
THINGS CHANGE THEN MAYBE IT
COULD BE THE FIRST TIME THERE
COULD BE MEASURABLE CHANGE IN
THIS AREA IN MANY YEARS IF THOSE
THINGS HAPPEN IN THAT SEQUENCE.
MARK: BECAUSE THE TARGET OF THE
ATTACK WAS A GAY NIGHTCLUB, THAT
HAS SPARKED AN OUTPOURING OF
SUPPORT AND SOLIDARITY WITH THE
LGBT COMMUNITY OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
VIGILS HAVE BEEN HELD ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD.
THE EIFFEL TOWER IS LIT UP IN
RAINBOW COLORS.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR GAY
RIGHTS?
JOHN: THE GAY RIGHTS MOVEMENT
HAS BEEN ADVANCING FOR A LONG
TIME.
WHAT WE SAW TODAY IS UNLIKE THE
GUN CONTROL DEBATE WHERE LINES
ARE CLEARLY DRAWN AND THE
PARTIES REMAIN FAR APART, THIS
IS SUDDENLY BRINGING ALONG A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
PREVIOUSLY PRONE TO TALK ABOUT
SYMPATHETIC ASPECTS TO THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS ARE
SUDDENLY OUT GIVING EXPRESSIONS
OF SYMPATHY.
IT MAKES IT A LOT HARDER FOR
THEM TO LATER OR SIMULTANEOUSLY
BE AGAINST OTHER MEASURES TO
HELP THAT COMMUNITY.
THERE IS NO WAY IN WHICH YOU
WANT TO THINK ABOUT SOMETHING
LIKE THIS AS BEING A POLITICAL
UPSIDE OR SILVER LINING.
THERE'S NO SILVERLIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES.
IT IS BRINGING OUT MORE EXPLICIT
SYMPATHY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
TRADITIONALLY BEEN SYMPATHETIC
TO LGBT WRITES IN THE LAST 24
HOURS.
MARK: AS MUCH AS LGBT WRITES
RIGHTS  HAVE ADVANCED, THIS IS
STILL GOING TO BE A HUGE DEAL.
YOU ARE RECEIVER PUBLICANS
TALKING ABOUT THE COMMUNITY IN
WAYS THAT THEY DID NOT BEFORE.
IT WILL MAKE IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
HAVE THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAVE A
SHARPLY DIFFERENT POSITION FROM
DEMOCRATS ON LGBT R NOW
IGHTS.
JOHN: HOW DIFFICULT WOULD IT BE
FOR AN ANTI-LGBT CADRE TO PUT
FORWARD-LOOKING LAWS LIKE THE
BATHROOM LAWS IN NORTH CAROLINA
TO TRY TO RESTRICT LGBT RIGHTS?
IT WE DEMONSTRATE AN INCREDIBLE
10 YEAR.
TIN EAR.
WE COME BACK, DONALD TRUMP AND
HILLARY CLINTON RESPONDING TO
THE ATTACK.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT WHAT THEY
SAID AND HOW IT MAY CHANGE THE
2016 PRESIDENTIAL RACE RIGHT
AFTER THIS QUICK RATE.
BREAK.
♪
JOHN: HILLARY CLINTON AND DONALD
TRUMP REACTED TO THE ORLANDO
SHOOTING OVER THE WEEKEND.
THEY LAID OUT THEIR PLANS AND
SPEECHES THIS AFTERNOON.
CLINTON SPOKE IN OHIO.
TRUMP SPOKE IN MANCHESTER NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
THEY EACH SPOKE ABOUT TERRORISM
GUN RIGHTS AND THE LGBT
COMMUNITY.
HILLARY CLINTON: THE ORLANDO
TERRORIST MAY BE DEAD BUT THE
VIRUS THE POISONED HIS MIND
REMAINS VERY MUCH ALIVE.
DONALD TRUMP: IT IS AN ASSAULT
ON THE ABILITY OF FREE PEOPLE TO
LIVE THEIR LIVES LOVE WHO THEY
WANT AND EXPRESS THEIR IDENTITY.
HILLARY CLINTON: THE ATTACK IN
ORLANDO MAKES IT EVEN MORE
CLEAR.
WE CANNOT CONTAIN THIS THREATS.
WE MUST DEFEAT IT.
DONALD TRUMP: WHEN I AM ELECTED
I WILL SUSPEND IMMIGRATION FROM
AREAS OF THE WORLD WHERE THERE
IS A PROVEN HISTORY OF TERRORISM
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES EUROPE
OR OUR ALLIES.
HILLARY CLINTON: INFLAMMATORY
ANTI-MUSLIM RHETORIC AND
THREATENING TO BAN THE FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS OF MUSLIM AMERICANS
HURTS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
MUSLIMS WHO LOVE FREEDOM AND
HATE TERROR.
DONALD TRUMP: HILLARY CLINTON
FOR MONTHS AND DESPITE SO MANY
ATTACKS REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO
EVEN SAY THE WORDS RADICAL
ISLAM.
AND SO I CHALLENGE FOR YESTERDAY
AND GUESS WHAT.
SHE WILL PROBABLY SAY THEM.
SHE SORT OF HAS SAID THEM.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
HILLARY CLINTON: WE HAVE TO STEM
THE FLOW OF JIHADISTS TO
AMERICA.
DONALD TRUMP: WE NEED TO TELL
THE TRUTH ABOUT RADICAL ISLAM.
WE NEED TO DO IT NOW.
HILLARY CLINTON: IF THE FBI IS
WATCHING YOU FOR SUSPECTED
TERRORIST LINKS YOU SHOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO JUST GO BUY A GUN
WITH NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
DONALD TRUMP: HER PLAN IS TO
DISARM LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS
ABOLISHING THE SECOND AMENDMENT
AND LEAVING ONLY THE BAD GUYS
AND TERRORISTS WITH GUNS.
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
HILLARY CLINTON: TO ALL THE LGBT
PEOPLE GRIEVING TODAY IN FLORIDA
YOU HAVE MILLIONS OF ALLIES WHO
WILL ALWAYS HAVE YOUR BACK.
>>
AND I AM ONE OF THEM.
DONALD TRUMP: AS YOURSELF WHO IS
REALLY THE FRIEND OF WOMEN AND
THE LGBT COMMUNITY?
DONALD TRUMP WITH ACTIONS, OR
HILLARY CLINTON WITH HER WORDS?
I WILL TELL YOU WITH A BETTER
FRIEND IS.
SOMEDAY I BELIEVE THAT WILL BE
PROVEN.
JOHN: BIG SPEECHES.
HAVE YOU THINK -- HOW DO YOU
THINK THE TRAGEDY IN ORLANDO
WILL AFFECT THE CAMPAIGN?
MARK: WE BOTH SAID THAT IF
THERE'S AN EVENT LIKE THIS IT
WILL ELEVATE NATIONAL SECURITY
MAYBE EVEN ON A PAR WITH THE
ECONOMY.
I THOUGHT HILLARY CLINTON IN THE
TEXT OF THE SPEECH BEING BOTH
TOUGH AND OPTIMISTIC AND IN
TERMS OF THE SEMIOTICS OF THE
EVENT ITSELF PRETTY CLOSE TO
FLAWLESS.
SHE IS IN A DIFFERENT ZONE NOW
IN TERMS OF COMMUNICATION.
I THOUGHT DONALD TRUMP GAVE
PEOPLE WHAT HE HAS ON OFFER.
TO BE A DIFFERENT KIND OF
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
TO SHAKE THINGS UP.
WHEN HE TALKED ABOUT BANNING
IMMIGRATION FROM COUNTRIES THAT
HAVE BEEN PROBLEMATIC.
YOU SEE HIM SIMULTANEOUSLY
GRAPPLING WITH HOW TO SEEM TOUGH
BUT ALSO TRYING TO CHANGE SOME
OF THE POLICIES THAT HAVE
BOTHERED PEOPLE IN HIS OWN
PARTY.
JOHN: HILLARY CLINTON BASICALLY
ARTICULATED WHAT HAS BEEN HER
POLICY ALL ALONG.
DONALD TRUMP WENT FURTHER.
YOU'RE SAYING HE'S TRYING TO
MOVE AWAY FROM BEING A RELIGIOUS
TEST TO BROADEN IT AND SAINT
SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON TERRORIST
TIES.
HE'S BASICALLY ADDING TO THE
MUSLIM BAND.
HE IS GONE FURTHER.
IT IS GOING TO BE A BIGGER
TARGET FOR DEMOCRATS.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS WHO WERE
WORRIED ABOUT HIM I DON'T THINK
HE DID A LOT EVEN WITH THE
TELEPROMPTER TO EASE THAT THEIR
CONCERNS.
HE SAID A BUNCH OF THINGS THAT
WERE NOT TRUE.
SUGGESTING THAT THE SHOOTER WAS
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
CASTING A VERY BROAD NET OVER
THE ENTIRE MUSLIM COMMUNITY AND
SAYING THEY KNOW WHEN THEY'RE
BAD PEOPLE IN THEIR MIDST AND
THEY ARE FAILING IS FOR THOSE
PEOPLE IN.
I THOUGHT  DONALD TRUMP GAVE
PEOPLE WHAT HE HAS GIVEN THEM.
I DON'T THINK HE DID A LOT TODAY
TO REASSURE REPUBLICANS WHO WERE
WORRIED ABOUT HIM AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
MARK: SECRETARY CLINTON AND 13
ARE CONFIDENT IN THEIR BONES
THAT ELIMINATING DONALD TRUMP IS
AN ACCEPTABLE ALTERNATIVE THAT
WILL BE MOST DECISIVE IN DOING
IT ON NATIONAL SECURITY.
THEY WILL SAY SHE PERFORMED AS A
STEADY LEADER AND HE PERFORMED
AS A HOTHEAD.
A LOT OF AMERICANS WILL LOOK AT
HER RECORD AND THE RECORD OF THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS AND SAY, HE MAY
BE A HOTHEAD BUT THAT IS WHAT WE
NEED.
WE MAY BE UNDERESTIMATING THE
EXTENT TO WHICH TRUMPS
PERFORMANCE HAS BROAD APPEAL.
JOHN: THE BIGGEST WEAKNESS THAT
SHE HAS IN TERMS OF HER STATURE,
SHE IS NOW PLAYING AT A VERY
HIGH LEVEL.
BUT THE BIGGEST WEAKNESS IS HER
RECORD.
DONALD TRUMP WILL BE ABLE TO
CONNECT THE OBAMA RECORD WITH
HER.
AND SAY THE COUNTRY IS NOT SAFER
.
THINGS ARE GETTING WORSE.
THERE IS A BAD TREND LINE HERE.
THE OBAMA POLICIES OF NOT HELPS
TO MAKE US SAFER.
SHE IS GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT.
THE HISTORY THAT SHE HAS OF
BEING PART OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
SHE IS GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THAT.
TRUMP CAN MAKE SOME HEADWAY ON
THAT FRONT.
THERE'S AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT WHAT
HE IS SAYING THERE'S GOING TO
MAKE A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
NERVOUS AND A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
GIDDY.
POLITICALLY.
COMING UP, WE'LL HEAD TO CAPITOL
HILL.
FOR HOW CONGRESS IS REACTING TO
THE TRAGEDY.
WE'LL TALK TO A TOP DEMOCRAT ON
THE HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE.
♪
MARK: WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
HORRIFIC SHOOTINGS IN ORLANDO.
JOINING US NOW IS THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN FROM MISSISSIPPI THE
RANKING MEMBER ON THE HOMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEE.
BENNIE THOMPSON.
GIVEN HOW OPEN AND FREE AMERICA
IS, SHOULD AMERICANS JUST ACCEPT
THIS KIND OF INCIDENT IS THE NEW
NORMAL? THOMPSON: I THINK IT IS
REALISTIC THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD START LOOKING AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND WHETHER OR NOT
THERE ARE SOME THINGS WE CAN DO.
TO MINIMIZE TRAGEDIES LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED IN ORLANDO.
WHAT YOU WILL SEE OVER THE NEXT
COMING WEEKS IS CONGRESS AND
OTHER PEOPLE LOOKING AT WHAT
COULD BE DONE DIFFERENTLY TO
PREVENT THESE ATTACKS.
MARK: WHAT IS ONE LEGAL CHANGE
THAT COULD MAKE THIS LESS
LIKELY?
THOMPSON: I'M HEARING CONCERN
THAT IF THE FBI HAD THIS PERSON
ON THEIR RADAR SCREEN FOR MAKING
TERRORIST OR EXTREMIST COMMENTS,
SHOULD THAT HAVE DISQUALIFIED
HIM FROM BUYING A WEAPON?
I THINK THE LAWYERS LOOK AT
THAT.
IT GOES TO THE NOTION OF WHAT
KIND OF BACKGROUND CHECKS WOULD
PICK UP SUCH A THING.
OR IF THE FBI CONDUCTED THE
INVESTIGATION WITH THAT
INFORMATION BE ENOUGH TO DENY A
PERSON THE RIGHT TO OWN A GUN?
VERSUS SOME OTHER THINGS RIGHT
OFF THE BAT.
WE LOOK AT SIMILAR THINGS AFTER
9/11.
THE BAND OF BEING ON AIRPLANES
NOW THAT BEFORE 9/11 WE COULD
DO.
BOX CUTTERS AND KNIVES.
WE CAN'T DO ANY OF THAT NOW.
WE'VE HARDENED TO THE COCKPIT
DOORS ON PASSENGER PLANES.
THE COCKPIT DOORS ON PASSENGER
PLANES.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO LOOK AT IT AND
SAY WHAT CAN WE DO TO PREVENT
OCCURRENCES LIKE THIS GOING
FORWARD.
JOHN: HE MAY HAVE BEEN JUST
INSPIRED BY THE IDEOLOGY.
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER IS THAT OF
ANY CONSEQUENCE?
THOMPSON: WE TALKED TO EXPERTS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
THEY ALL SAY THAT A FREE AND
OPEN INTERNET IS A LABORATORY
FOR JUST ABOUT ANYTHING YOU
IMAGINE.
FOR SOMEONE WHO FEELS THAT ISIS
IS AN IDEOLOGY THAT THEY WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEY COULD VERY
WELL BECOME RADICALIZED OVER THE
INTERNET.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY FOR A LONG TIME HAVE
BEEN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
NOTION OF THE LONE WOLF.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THEY ARE NOT PEOPLE WHO CAME
HERE FROM A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
BUT THEY DO TERRORIST RELATED
THINGS.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO IDENTIFY LONE
WOLVES?
THE EXPERTS ARE LOOKING AT IT
AND I THINK IF WE CAN WE WELL.
WE ARE A NATION OF LAWS.
CIVIL RIGHTS AND CIVIL LIBERTIES
COME INTO PLAY.
WE STILL HAVE TO LOOK AT
EVERYTHING.
JOHN: THANK YOU.
WHEN WE COME BACK SOME REPORTING
ON WHERE THINGS STAND NOW IN
ORLANDO.
AFTER THIS.
♪
JOHN: AS WE COVER ALL THE ANGLES
OF SUNDAY'S SHOOTING IN ORLANDO,
OUR NEXT GUEST JOINS US FROM THE
STREETS OF ORLANDO.
KATE SNOW, THANK YOU FOR COMING
ON "ALL DO WITH RESPECT -- "WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT."
IT IS A HUGE SHOCK THAT IS SENT
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY.
GIVE US A SENSE OF HOW THE
VARIOUS AFFECTED COMMUNITIES AND
THE CITY MORE BROADLY IS DEALING
WITH THE FALLOUT FROM WHAT
HAPPENED OVER THE WEEKEND.
GUEST: IT IS HARD.
IT HAS BEEN 48 HOURS, AND PEOPLE
ARE STILL ABSORBING THE SHOCK.
EVERYONE HAS A LOOK ON THEIR
FACE, WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO OUR
COMMUNITY?
I AM STANDING IN FRONT OF PULSE,
A COUPLE BLOCKS DOWN THAT WAY,
AND WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET
CLOSE TO THE SCENE.
IT HAS BEEN HARD ABSORBING
THE FACT 49 LIVES WERE LOST IN A
BUILDING.
YOU FEEL DISTANT BECAUSE THE
POLICE ARE KEEPING US AWAY.
OBVIOUSLY, THEY HAVE TO SPEND
DAYS PROCESSING IT.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH THE
SHOOTER'S COMPUTER AND DIGITAL
TRAIL TO FIGURE OUT MORE ABOUT
HIM.
WE LEARNED A LOT MORE ABOUT HIM
TODAY FROM THE FBI DIRECTOR IN
TERMS OF ALL THE TIMES OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS HE HAD SWORN
ALLEGIANCE OR SAID HE SUPPORTED
VARIOUS GROUPS OVERSEAS.
WE LEARNED MORE ABOUT THE
SHOOTER, BUT WE ARE STARTING TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE VICTIMS.
JOHN: THE LGBT COMMUNITY HAS
OBVIOUSLY FACED HATE CRIMES AND
BEEN SUBJECT TO THOSE CRIMES.
THIS PARTICULAR CRIME IS TIED UP
WITH THE ISSUE OF ISLAMIC
TERRORISM.
TO THE EXTENT YOU HAVE HAD
CONTACT WITH VICTIMS' FAMILIES,
HOW ARE THEY DEALING MENTALLY
WITH BEING HIT WITH A DOUBLE
BARREL HATE CRIME?
GUEST: I TALKED TO A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ABOUT THAT VERY THING.
LEADERS IN THE LGBT COMMUNITY
HERE IN NATIONWIDE.
I WAS TALKING TO A CITY
COUNCILWOMAN EARLIER, THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY MEMBER OF CITY
COUNCIL.
SHE TALKED ABOUT THE SHOCK AND
FEELING THIS WAS REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE ANGER THAT IS OUT THERE,
THE RAGE THAT STILL EXISTS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
SHE SAYS HATRED IS NOT THE
ANSWER.
WHAT WE SAW SATURDAY NIGHT IS
THAT THE HATRED IS STILL VERY
MUCH ALIVE.
I DO NOT KNOW IF WE HAVE A
SOUND, BUT I ASKED HER ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S COMMENT TODAY.
HE SAID THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
ASSAULT WEAPONS IN THIS COUNTRY
AND IT IS IMPRACTICAL TO CONTROL
ALL THOSE WEAPONS.
FOR RESPONSE WAS, IF WE ARE NOT
GOING TO TALK ABOUT GUN CONTROL
RIGHT NOW, WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT IT?
THERE IS THIS INTERSECTION OF
SEVERAL THINGS, THE POTENTIAL
FOR TERRORIST CONNECTIONS, OF
GAY RIGHTS AND GAY PRIDE AND
THAT COMMUNITY STRUGGLING TO
COME TO TERMS WITH WHAT
HAPPENED, AND THE WEAPONRY USED
AND THE QUESTIONS COMING UP
ABOUT GUN RIGHTS.
MARK: ANOTHER INTERESTING ASPECT
OF THE INTERVIEW YOU DID WITH
THE COUNCILWOMAN WHO KNOWS THE
OWNERS OF THE CLUB WELL WAS HER
DENOUNCING THOSE WHO WANT TO
HOLD VIGILS AROUND THE CITY.
TALK ABOUT WHY SHE HAD THAT
POINT OF VIEW AND HOW BIG AN
ISSUE THAT IS FOR THE CITY AT
LARGE.
GUEST: I WAS A BIT SURPRISED,
TAKEN ABACK, WHEN SHE SAID WE DO
NOT NEED MORE CANDLELIGHT
VIGILS.
I SAID, WHY?
SHE SAID, THERE ARE PLANS NEARBY
TO HAVE ANOTHER CANDLELIGHT
VIGIL.
THAT TAKES PEOPLE AWAY FROM THE
CRIME SCENE BEHIND ME.
POLICE OFFICERS HAVE TO STAFF
AND SURROUND A CROWD AND MAKE
SURE IT DOES NOT GET OUT OF
HAND, MAKE SURE THERE IS
SECURITY.
HER POINT WAS THAT ALL WE NEED
RIGHT NOW IS TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE AND HELP THE
FAMILIES, HELP THE VICTIMS, HELP
THOSE WHO ARE SURVIVORS.
WE DO NOT NEED TO HAVE GROUPS
COMING IN TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE MOMENT.
SHE IS SENSITIVE THAT SOME
GROUPS HAVE COME HERE FROM OTHER
PLACES OUTSIDE OF ORLANDO.
SHE THINKS THEY JUST WANT THE
LIMELIGHT, A LITTLE BIT OF
ATTENTION.
EVERYONE WOULD AGREE THE
ATTENTION SHOULD BE ON THE
FAMILIES WHO LOST LOVED ONES AND
THE PEOPLE WHO SURVIVED.
I MEAN, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WALKING AROUND WHO WERE
THERE SATURDAY NIGHT.
THEY ARE HERE WITH US STILL.
THAT SHOULD BE CELEBRATED.
MARK: WE KNOW FROM NEW YORK
AFTER 9/11 AND WASHINGTON AS
WELL, OTHER CITIES HAVE DEALT
WITH HORRIBLE THINGS LIKE THIS.
LEADERSHIP HAS TO BE STRONG AND
TALK ABOUT HOW THE CITY WILL
FIGHT BACK.
THERE IS ALWAYS SOME JITT
ERINESS.
HOW MUCH OF THAT ARE YOU FEELING
THERE, THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
RELAXED AND WORRIED ABOUT OTHER
ATTACKS?
GUEST: IT IS INTERESTING.
COMPARED TO OTHER, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, WE HAVE ALL BEEN
TO TOO MANY SCENES LIKE THIS, I
DO NOT FEEL AS MUCH A SENSE FROM
PEOPLE HERE THAT THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT SOMETHING
HAPPENING AGAIN IMMINENTLY.
THERE IS A COLLECTIVE SENSE THIS
WAS ONE MAN THAT, ACCORDING TO
FAMILY AND FRIENDS, HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF INSTABILITY.
HIS OWN FATHER DESCRIBING IT TO
MY COLLEAGUES AS SOMEONE WHO
STRUGGLED WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES.
THERE IS A SENSE THIS IS ONE
ISOLATED GUY, BUT THAT SAID, THE
CONNECTION OVERSEAS AND THE FACT
THAT HE WANTED TO SWEAR
ALLEGIANCE TO ISIS HAS THE
COUNTRY ON EDGE.
THIS IS A VERY DIFFERENT THING
FOR THE GAY COMMUNITY, TOO.
WE HAVE HAD HATE CRIMES AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS, BUT TO HAVE 49
PEOPLE MASSACRED IN A GAY CLUB
IS DIFFERENT.
JOHN: WE IN THE POLITICAL WORLD
ARE LOOKING AT THIS TO SOME
EXTENT THROUGH A POLITICAL LENS.
WE WATCHED DONALD TRUMP AND
HILLARY CLINTON RESPOND.
I KNOW YOU ARE BUSY AND DID NOT
HAVE A CHANCE TO SEE BOTH
SPEECHES.
GUEST: I SAW A LARGE PART OF
BOTH OF THEM.
JOHN: OK.
I'M CURIOUS HOW MUCH PEOPLE DOWN
THERE ARE PAYING ATTENTION.
COULD THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY HAVE -- CARE LESS WHAT
DONALD TRUMP AND HILLARY CLINTON
HAVE TO SAY?
GUEST: I THINK IT IS TOO SOON
FOR MOST PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE
WHO ARE DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO
WHAT HAPPENED SATURDAY NIGHT.
THEY ARE STILL IN MOURNING,
TRYING TO PROCESS WHAT HAPPENED.
THEY ARE NOT WATCHING CABLE NEWS
AND MSNBC, TUNING IN TO SEE THE
CLINTON OR TRUMP SPEECHES.
THERE IS A SENSITIVITY YEAR, TO
GO BACK TO WHAT THE COUNCILWOMAN
SAID, DO NOT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE MOMENT.
THEY DO NOT WANT POLITICIANS OR
ANYONE ELSE TO BE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS TRAGEDY TO
MAKE A POLITICAL POINT OR SCORE
POINTS.
JOHN: OK.
KATE SNOW, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING DOWN THERE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
NEXT, MORE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S
SPEECH IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
WE WILL TALK WITH A SENIOR TRUMP
ADVISOR WHEN WE COME RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: THE IMAGE OF THE EIFFEL TO
WER LIT UP TONIGHT, ONE OF THE
COMMEMORATIONS AROUND THE WORLD
FOR WHAT HAPPENED IN ORLANDO.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THOSE EVENTS, MARY MADELINE, WHO
IS A MEMBER OF THE LIBERTARIAN
PARTY.
SHE IS IN OUR DC BUREAU, ALONG
WITH BARRY BENNETT, SENIOR
CAMPAIGN ADVISOR TO DONALD
TRUMP.
MARY, I WOULD LIKE TO ASK FOR
YOUR SENSE OF HOW THE GOVERNMENT
AND POLITICAL SYSTEM IS
RESPONDING TO SERVE THE PUBLIC
INTEREST IN THE WAKE OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN ORLANDO.
GUEST: NOT WELL.
YOU SAID TO YOUR PREVIOUS
ANCHORETTE HOW PEOPLE CARE DOWN
THERE.
THEY SHOULD NOT CARE LESS.
WHAT HAVE THE CHATTERING CLASS
BEEN TALKING ABOUT?
GUN RESTRICTIONS, BACKGROUND
CHECKS, ALL OF WHICH WOULD HAVE
MADE A DIFFERENCE.
IT IS CALCULATED.
IT IS HOGWASH MISDIRECTION.
IT IS NOT BEING HANDLED WELL,
BUT BUT IT IS A POLITICAL
CALCULATION.
I DID NOT LEAVE BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
MARK: I DID NOT SAY YOU LEFT
BECAUSE OF HIM.
I SAID YOU LEFT IN THE WAKE OF
THE NOMINATION FIGHT.
GUEST: YOU ARE RIGHT.
I RETRACT THAT.
MARK: BARRY, TALK ABOUT THE
CAMPAIGN'S DECISION TO GIVE THE
KIND OF SPEECH HE DID TODAY,
CHANGE THE SCHEDULE.
WHAT WENT INTO THAT DECISION?
GUEST: IT IS A GREAT EXAMPLE OF
OUR GOVERNMENT NOT DOING ITS
JOB.
WE KNOW WHAT CAUSES SOMEONE TO
SUDDENLY RADICALIZE.
WE NEED TO KNOW.
WE NEED TO KNOW WE CAN KEEP
THOSE PEOPLE OUT OF THE COUNTRY,
FROM IMMIGRATING HERE.
OUR GOVERNMENT HAS TOTALLY
FAILED AT THIS.
WE ARE ASKING THE FBI TO CLEAN
IT UP.
IT IS AN IMPOSSIBLE TASK.
IT IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE,
UNFORTUNATELY, OF GOVERNMENT
FAILING.
THAT WILL PROBABLY BE A
LONG-LASTING EFFECT.
GUEST: I DO NOT KNOW IF IT IS
GOVERNMENT FAILURE.
IT IS A CULTURAL FAILURE IN THAT
WE DISINCENTIVIZE COMING
FORWARD, IN THE FT. HOOD CASE,
THE SAN BERNARDINO CASE.
WE DO NOT WANT TO APPEAR
INTOLERANT.
I AM PRETTY SURE THE FBI IS
DOING THEIR JOB AS WELL AS THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO WITH THE RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT UNDER WHICH THEY ARE
ACTING.
IF PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO COME
FORWARD, WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
THESE KINDS OF TRAGEDIES.
JOHN: BARRY, LET ME ASK YOU
SOMETHING ABOUT MR. TRUMP SAID
THIS MORNING ABOUT MR. OBAMA.
HE DOES NOT GET IT.
OR HE GETS IT BETTER THAN ANYONE
UNDERSTANDS.
EITHER ONE IS UNACCEPTABLE.
WE ARE LED BY A MAN THAT IS NOT
TOUGH, NOT SMART, OR HAS
SOMETHING ELSE IN MIND.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THOSE
QUOTES MEAN?
NOT THE PART ABOUT HIM NOT
GETTING IT.
WHAT IS THE SOMETHING ELSE IN
MIND OR THAT HE GETS IT BETTER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE UNDERSTANDS?
GUEST: I THINK WHAT HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT IS HE JUST STUCK
HIS HEAD IN THE SAND AND REFUSES
TO CALL IT WHAT IT IS, RADICAL
ISLAMIC TERRORISM.
IT IS ALL POLITICALLY CORRECT.
WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HATE
ANYBODY, EVEN TERRORISTS.
THAT KIND OF ATTITUDE, WHICH IS
NOT HELPING THE CASE.
JOHN: THOSE ARE BOTH CONSISTENT
WITH "HE DOES NOT GET IT," OR HE
IS NOT TOUGH, NOT SMART.
IT IS THE OTHER PART I'M CURIOUS
ABOUT.
HE GETS IT BETTER THAN ANYONE
ELSE UNDERSTANDS OR HE HAS
SOMETHING ELSE IN MIND.
WHAT DOES THAT ALLUDE TO?
GUEST: I THINK HE HAS SOMETHING
ELSE PLANNED.
HE PLANS TO THROW IT ALL ON THE
NEXT PRESIDENT.
JOHN: MANY PEOPLE THINK MR.
TRUMP WAS SUGGESTING THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS SOMEHOW
COMPLICIT.
IS THAT NOT HOW WE SHOULD
INTERPRET THAT?
GUEST: THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT I AM
SAYING.
GUEST: MAYBE YOU COULD INTERPRET
IT AS HE KNOWS THAT OBAMA
SUPPORTS OPEN, LAWLESS BORDERS,
WHICH TRUMP DOES NOT.
MIDI HE THINKS OBAMA IS TURNING
A BLIND EYE BECAUSE IT COMPORTS
WITH HIS PLANS.
JOHN: MARY, TODAY, MR. TRUMP
GAVE HIS SPEECH AND SAID HE WAS
STILL IN FAVOR OF A TEMPORARY
BAN ON MUSLIMS COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
HE WANTS TO BAN IMMIGRATION FROM
COUNTRIES WITH HISTORIC TIES
WITH TERRORISM.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THOSE
PROPOSALS?
GUEST: I THINK IT IS SORT OF A
SLEDGEHAMMER.
THE ESSENCE OF IT IS CORRECT.
WE COULD CERTAINLY HAVE MORE
SCRUTINY OF PEOPLE COMING FROM
KNOWN TERRORIST COUNTRIES.
WE SHOULD DO DEEPER BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
WE SHOULD HAVE EXTRA SCRUTINY.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE LONE WOLF
OR KNOWN WOLF SITUATION.
WE NEED TO DO SCRUTINY ON THESE
LONE WOLVES AND KNOWN WOLVES.
THEY HAVE NO LEADERS.
THEY DO NOT CALL UP ISIS CENTRAL
AND SAY, I AM PUNCHING IN TODAY.
THEY DO IT THE WAY THEY DO IT.
IT IS CONSTANT FOR THEM.
WE NEED TO DO BETTER SCRUTINY.
WE NEED IMMIGRATION REFORM,
ANYWAYS.
PART OF THE IMMIGRATION REFORM
WOULD BE TO PAY SPECIAL
ATTENTION IN THE WAY THE
ISRAELIS DO, TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING FROM COUNTRIES THAT
HARBOR TERRORISTS.
MARK: MARY MATALIN, BENNETT,
STAND BY.
WE WILL COME BACK AND TALK MORE
ABOUT THE ATTACKS IN JUST A
MOMENT.
IF YOU'RE LISTENING TO US IN
WASHINGTON DC, YOU CAN LISTEN TO
US ON BLOOMBERG 99.1 FM IN
WASHINGTON.
♪
JOHN: WE ARE BACK WITH THE
RENOWNED REPUBLICAN, NOW
LIBERTARIAN, MARY MATALIN, AND
BARRY BENNETT.
JUST BEFORE WE WENT ON THE AIR,
WE GOT WORD LOOKING AT DONALD
TRUMP'S FACEBOOK PAGE, BASED ON
INCREDIBLY INADEQUATE COVERAGE,
WE ARE REVOKING THE PRESS
CREDENTIALS OF THE WASHINGTON
POST.
THE EXECUTIVE EDITOR HAS SAID
THAT REVOCATION IS NOTHING LESS
THAN A REPUDIATION OF A
INDEPENDENT PRESS.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THE
WASHINGTON POST HAS DONE TO
JUSTIFY YOUR CAMPAIGN REVOKING
CREDENTIALS?
GUEST: I WISH I COULD.
I HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO TALK TO
THE CAMPAIGN SINCE I SAW THE
FACEBOOK POST.
JOHN: MARY, YOU HAVE DEALT WITH
THE PRESS FOR A LONG TIME,
SOMETIMES IN ADVERSARIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IS THERE A CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH
YOU COULD IMAGINE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A CAMPAIGN REVOKING THE
CREDENTIALS OF THE WASHINGTON
POST?
GUEST: PROBABLY NOT, BUT THERE
HAVE BEEN OCCASIONS WHERE I
SLEPT ACROSS THE FACE VARIOUS
REPORTERS AT CARMAX ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I AM -- TARMACS ACROSS THE
I AM NOT SURE IT MATTERS.
MR. TRUMP HAS A LINE OF
COMMUNICATION AROUND THE COUNTRY
THAT TRANSCENDS THE WASHINGTON
POST.
IT IS OFF MESSAGE.
I GUESS THAT IS ON MESSAGE FOR
HIM.
JOHN: SHOULD THE PRESS RIGHT NOW
TAKE THIS AS A WARNING SIGN THAT
, IF IT DISPLEASES THE CAMPAIGN,
IT FACES RETRIBUTION OF THIS
KIND?
THAT IS THE INFERENCE I WOULD
DRAW FROM THIS ACTION, THAT
EVERYBODY IS ON NOTICE.
GUEST: I DO NOT KNOW IT WAS
MEANT AS A WARNING SHOT.
IN TODAY'S SOCIAL MEDIA AGE, THE
PRESS IS REMARKABLY LESS
IMPORTANT.
MORE PEOPLE READ THAT POST THEN
THE WASHINGTON POST, I ASSURE
YOU.
JOHN: I ASSUME YOU ARE NOT
SAYING THAT THE PRESS,
TELEVISION NETWORKS, THE
WASHINGTON POST, IS NOW
IRRELEVANT AND SHOULD BE
DISREGARDED.
GUEST: IN THE DAY, THAT WAS THE
ONLY WAY TO GET YOUR MESSAGE
OUT.
EVERY STOP ON THE PLANE WERE
YOUR ONLY CHANCE IS TO GET YOUR
MESSAGE OUT.
THAT IS NOT THE CASE TODAY.
MARK: BARRY, IS INAPPROPRIATE
FOR A CAMPAIGN TO ALLOW OR NOT
ALLOW COVERAGE OF A NEWS
ORGANIZATION BASED ON THAT
ORGANIZATION'S COVERAGE?
IS THAT APPROPRIATE?
GUEST: IT IS NOT APPROPRIATE,
BUT THAT HAPPENS EVERY DAY.
MARK: I UNDERSTAND.
YOU ARE SAYING THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN HAS NEVER DENIED A NEWS
ORGANIZATION ACCESS BASED ON
COVERAGE?
IT HAS BEEN WIDELY REPORTED --
GUEST: POLITICO, FOR INSTANCE,
HAS BEEN BANNED FROM A LOT OF
EVENTS, BUT IS -- IT DOES NOT
STOP THEM FROM REPORTING.
MARK: BUT IS IT APPROPRIATE TO
BAN AN ORGANIZATION BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT LIKE THE COVERAGE?
GUEST: YOU CAN CERTAINLY BAN
ACCESS, ABSOLUTELY.
GUEST: I DO NOT THINK IT IS
INAPPROPRIATE.
MARK: NOT INAPPROPRIATE TO SAY
WE DO NOT LIKE THE STORY?
YOU CANNOT COVER US?
GUEST: IF YOU DID NOT LIKE
COVERAGE OF A PARTICULAR
REPORTER, YOU COULD CHOOSE NOT
TO DO INTERVIEWS WITH THEM.
MARK: IT IS NOT ABOUT
INTERVIEWS.
IT IS ABOUT WHETHER YOU DENIED
PRESS CREDENTIALS TO COVER
EVENTS OTHER NEWS ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ALLOWED TO COVER.
MARY, IS THAT APPROPRIATE?
GUEST: I THINK IT IS A WASTE OF
TIME, MAKING A BIG PRONOUNCEMENT
ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW BETTER THAN ANYBODY
THERE ARE WAYS TO BAN OR DE-
CREDENTIAL PRESS WHO YOU WANT TO
PUNISH.
THAT IS AS OLD AS CAMPAIGNS ARE.
WHAT IS DISCONCERTING IS MAKING
A BIG HOO-HA ABOUT IT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, WHEN MR.
TRUMP MADE A BIG HOO-HA IN THE
NEW YORK TIMES AND IT COLLAPSE
ON ITSELF, IT REINFORCED A
META-MESSAGE OF HIS.
HE NEEDS TO GET MORE ON A POLICY
AND PRINCIPLE MESSAGE.
MARK: JUST TO BE CLEAR --
JOHN: GO AHEAD.
MARK: IT IS NOT ABOUT WHETHER IT
HAS BEEN DONE BEFORE.
I DO NOT THINK IT HAS BEEN DONE
ON THIS SCALE IN MY CAREER.
IT IS NOT ABOUT WHETHER YOU CAN
GET AWAY WITH IT.
IT IS A MATTER OF PRINCIPLE.
NEWS ORGANIZATION SHOULD BE
DENIED COVERAGE TO OPEN PRESS
EVENTS BECAUSE OF THE CONTENT OF
THINGS THEY HAVE WRITTEN OR SAID
PREVIOUSLY.
I HAVE NOT HEARD EITHER OF YOU
SAY YOU THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE
OR NOT.
GUEST: IT IS INEFFECTIVE.
IT IS INAPPROPRIATE IN A
CAMPAIGN BECAUSE IT IS
INEFFECTIVE.
GO AHEAD AND COVER IT.
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE WAS MAKING A
BIG HOO-HA OUT OF IT.
WE AGREE IT IS INAPPROPRIATE.
ONE OF US, WHO DOES NOT WORK FOR
TRUMP, IS SAYING IT WAS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
JOHN: WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK.
♪
MARK: A LOT MORE COVERAGE ON THE
ORLANDO SHOOTING AND ITS
IMPLICATIONS ON POLITICS ON
BLOOMBERGPOLITICS.COM.
COMING UP, EMILY CHANG SPEAKS TO
THE CEO'S OF MICROSOFT AND
LINKEDIN.
♪
MARK: YOU ARE WATCHING
"BLOOMBERG WEST."
HOSPITAL OFFICIALS SAY FIVE OF
53 PEOPLE WOUNDED IN SUNDAY'S
MASS SHOOTING IN ORLANDO ARE
STILL IN GRAVE CONDITION.
THE ATTACK LEFT 50 PEOPLE DEAD,
INCLUDING THE SHOOTER, KILLED IN
A GUN BATTLE WITH POLICE.
INVESTIGATORS ARE TRYING TO
DETERMINE A MOTIVE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA SAYS THE CASE IS
BEING TREATED AS A TERRORISM
INVESTIGATION.
AIRFRANCE IS ABLE TO GET 80% OF
ITS LIFE IN THE AIR DESPITE A
STRIKE BY PILOTS.
1/4 OF THE PILOTS HAVE WALKED
OUT BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO WORK
MORE HOURS WITHOUT MORE PAY.
OTHER EMPLOYEES HAVE WALKED OUT
BECAUSE OF DISPUTES INCLUDING
NEW LABOR REFORMS.
IN SOUTH AFRICA, OSCAR PISTORI